hey guys Daniel Moritz from dlm moral
lifestyle here now I've got a question
for you if you struggle with low
self-esteem lack of energy low sex drive
depression weight gain moodiness or even
thinner hair it might be because your
testosterone levels are too low most of
the time so how do you improve it well
the best place to start is by eating the
right foods that will increase your
testosterone naturally so that's what
I'm quickly going to talk about in this
video let's get the stakes by mistakes
make you strong now just very quick if
it's your first time here on my channel
consider subscribing so you won't miss
any of the next videos now you need to
know that if you constantly overeat or
change your nutritional plan it can and
probably will disrupt your testosterone
levels so you need to maintain a good
consistent nutritional plan of a healthy
protein fat and carbs so if that in mind
let's start with the first food type
that will increase your testosterone
fish like tuna sardines and salmon grass
medical University in Austria found that
vitamin D boost testosterone by up to
92% and tuna has a lot of it so does
sardines and salmon
now don't go overboard but eating fish
twice a week will be good enough
boy stirs now zinc is very very
important for men because it helps with
sperm health and oysters have more zinc
than any other food out there if you
don't have enough zinc in your body you
might experience impotence or struggle a
little you know what I mean but you can
also get zinc from nuts beans poultry
red meat and other shellfish
pomegranates there's been a lot of
studies on pomegranate just to show what
an amazing fruit this really is if not
only increase your testosterone but it
also increases your mood and your blood
pressure so it's really good for your
heart and also for some of you that
experience a lot of stress eggs now
there's a lot of you guys that like to
work out and throw away the egg yolk but
that's a huge mistake because the egg
yolks there are the guys that increase
your testosterone levels they are packed
with vitamin D and actually has more
nutrients than the egg white now you
might say well yeah Daniel but if I eat
egg yolks it's gonna increase my
cholesterol well newer studies actually
show us just how important the egg yolk
really is and you can eat 3 eggs without
it affecting your cholesterol according
to a study from a University in
Connecticut beef now I know this is a
trigger for a lot of people who don't
like to eat beef but let me just give
you the facts
beef boost testosterone and liver for
example is a big source of vitamin D and
ground beef also increases your zinc and
I've already explained how important
zinc is so let's move on next up is
honey yes believe it or not honey has a
mineral that's called boron and that
increases your testosterone
it also has nitric oxide which opens up
blood vessels so please guys instead of
using unhealthy sugar used honey instead
but also remember everything has above
so don't overdo it
rapes not only does it taste good but it
also increased your testosterone and it
makes your sperm more active by
increasing the ability to swim now it's
actually the skin here from the grape
that has the super ability now as a
bonus because you watched all the way to
the end of the video I'm gonna quickly
mention a few more foods that will
increase your testosterone cabbage
garlic ginger leafy green vegetables
extra virgin olive oil and onions now if
you want to know which kind of food will
destroy your testosterone then check out
this video and I'll see you there
just guys